marine veteran trevor reed is back in
the u.s after nearly three years in a
russian jail his family says he was held
hostage there reed was flown to the to
his home state of texas overnight after
being released in what was a surprise
prisoner swap negotiated with the
kremlin congressman august fluger posted
this picture with reid and his family
from the tarmac we're just so happy to
see them all together again nancy cordes
at the white house for us
nancy his family never gave up good
morning what an amazing conclusion to
this saga tony yes trevor reed arrived
in san antonio overnight he was
evaluated by military doctors on the
plane and now he's going to get an
in-depth evaluation at a military
hospital that's expected to last several
days the u.s made a major concession in
order to get him home one that his
parents say probably saved his life
trevor reed's first few steps as a free
man were filmed by russian state media
flown from moscow to turkey he crossed
paths on the tarmac with convicted drug
smuggler konstantin yaroshenko who was
returned to russia by the u.s as part of
a prisoner exchange hi everybody reid's
parents at home in texas got the call
they had been waiting for for nearly
three years it's going to really hit us
when we get to put our arms around him
and hug him
the 30 year marine corps veteran was
serving a nine-year prison sentence
accused of drunkenly assaulting two
russian police officers in 2019.
president biden took credit for the
prisoner swap wednesday saying he made
the difficult decision after learning
that reid might have tuberculosis and
was coughing up blood several times a
day
the state department says it's still
working to free two other americans in
russian custody wnba star brittany
griner who was arrested in february and
paul whelan a marine corps veteran
accused of espionage who was detained
one year before reed in 2018. what about
the others that are left behind whelan's
twin brother worries that the u.s used
up a crucial bargaining chip when it
turned over yaroshenko yesterday are we
all starting back at square one are we
all going back and looking for a new
concession to get paul released because
it's not at all clear to me today
what the us government can do now that
it couldn't have done yesterday our
hearts go out to them trevor reed's
parents said they had feared their son
would refuse to leave prison if whelan
wasn't released too he doesn't want to
leave another marine there we hope that
the wieland family is going to be having
a reunion just like ours soon
and paul whelan's family is now sharing
his reaction to trevor reed's release
here it is he says why was i left behind
while i am pleased that trevor is home
with his family i have been held on a
fictitious charge of espionage for 40
months why hasn't more been done to
secure my release
and the wife of brittany griner posted
this overnight as i do everything in my
power to get bg home i do know the pain
of having your loved one detained in a
foreign country that level of pain can
only be remedied by a safe return home
griner by the way has yet to be even
charged her next hearing is scheduled
for may 19th in russia vlad
we're certainly hoping for the best for
brittany greiner and paul whalen but it
is a happy conclusion for trevor reed
and his family nancy thank you very much